E aí
e eu quero saudar o meu pai e a sua
presença eterna na minha vida saudar os
meus ancestrais minha família meus
amigos todo mundo que corre comigo
Olá quero saudar o hip-hop o funk a
literatura periférica e cada sarau e
tayslan que mantém viva essa literatura
nas quebradas do país quero saudar dona
Vera saudades mais de Maio
o e dizer que assim como doutor King eu
também tenho um sonho
é o sonho é voltar quem obedece que se
dane os que manda quem sabe meu povo
novo em minhas preces faz de cada
quebrada o seu próprio Reino de uma
camda é que cada vez que a gente rima o
que a gente dança é uma lembrança de que
nessas nossas andanças Não Existe Pecado
era tudo bem melhor por aqui até que
chegou o povo que acredita em diabo
agora nós aprendi cedo demais que não
tem Fórmula Mágica para pais mas cada
vez que eu não me mata eu consigo ouvir
o aplauso dos meus vocês traz é que os
pretos velhos são sempre comigo então
desculpa se a minha rima às vezes parece
triste demais e meu olho sempre cansado
é que eu aprendi a entender o mundo
brisando no morro do meu quarto da minha
mãe dizendo que eu tinha que estudar
para ser gente então como nós faz
diferentes e por aqui não tem vibranium
que salve a gente se só a bala come e
cela proibições untada verbo medo em
cada verso desespero em cada viela
e quem vem se torna grande demais então
desculpa se na minha poesia só tem
espaço para quem perde todo dia tipo meu
pai tipo um bêbado na esquina esse Deus
ajuda Quem cedo madruga e não deve saber
que eu não durmo mais uma vez só
pensando em como mostrar para cada
menino daqui que ele também é um rei eu
fiz as pazes com Xangô e ele me ensinou
a ser gay é que eu sou filho do caçador
que ar ou eu não sei respeitar patrão
padrão nem mais fé vem tem para rodovias
e tem tema cadeias fé em Deus e nas
crianças da favela e nem precisa para o
dia porque isso aqui é só nosso ensaio
mas se hoje nós está vivo então agradece
as mães de Maio porque podia ser a minha
mãe só que fita meio que era morreu de
tristeza de banzo de espera então a cota
agora é fazer virar o sonho da dona Vera
e de todas as mães que morreram
esperando e justiça então fica decretado
não morre mais nenhum menino nosso na
mão da polícia
É eu sei até hoje nós não sou a Marilda
Mas calma muita luz a revolução aqui é
segurar o sorriso Então olha para o céu
e agradece o Nordeste força de Lampião
para enfrentar os ganks e cresce porque
nem as pragas do Egito mata igual essas
festas até no Natal lá na rua tinha uma
mãe chorando para dar mateusa para o
Daleste mas não tem direito ao luto e
muito menos direito ao fluxo eu ando
cada vez mais só
é só que ainda pelo caráter que eu
escolho com quem eu vou do lado e juntos
nós atravessa o mar vermelho ouvindo um
rap bolado porque se ontem foi silêncio
e bando hoje nós somos loucos anunciando
sonhos no microfone Oxalá vai nos
recompensar por cada noite dormida com
fome não não vai cuidar de cada corpo
dos nossos que sobe então mantenha-se
vivo mantenha-se viva e verá que cada
Pantera Negra tem seu próprio jeito de
reinar alguns usa boné no lugar de coroa
na minha cabeça a única voz que ainda me
guia é a voz da Minha Coroa
e eu acredito que a ideia negra é mais
radical e mais importante
é a ideia de liberdade é a ideia da
Abolição
E aí quando eu falo de abolição e de
liberdade eu falo de um mundo sem
escravidão mas eu também falo sobre o
mundo sem cadeia um mundo sem violência
policial um mundo sem Manicômio o mundo
sem Grade nas escolas é esse mundo que
eu sonho porque muitas ideias negras
foram assassinadas no massacre que a
polícia fez o fluxo de baile funk no
Paraisópolis muitas ideias negras também
foram assassinadas em mais de 2006 pela
mesma polícia Então essas idéias que eu
acho importante também grávidas na minha
poesia na minha arte na nossa literatura
e não se trata nunca se tratou de um
pedido por liberdade é um decreto é uma
exigência as nossas crianças vão viver
num mundo onde elas possam ser livres e
como eu disse eu faço parte o Clio e
faço parte da cena do movimento de
literatura periférica dos islands dos
saraus eu acredito nessa arte como uma
forma de ser livre a Carolina Maria de
Jesus é o nosso sol a nossa estrela
maior da literatura negra na literatura
periférica ela dizia assim eu quero ser
livre igualzinho ao só
Oi e aí grandeza e liberdade tem muito a
ver não eu não juntas
Olá eu sou filho de pais que não
aprenderam a ler EA escrever eu acredito
que é muito grandioso para mim e sendo
grandioso é muito Libertador para mim
não só para mim mas sumiu não vocês traz
E por que vão vim depois de mim poder
fazer literatura poder fazer poesia e
comunicar as nossas ideias através da
poesia eu conduz oficinas de poesia de
rima e esses dias uma dessas atividades
com adolescentes presos um deles falou
assim a gente aqui tem que no mesmo
destino o mesmo caminho mesmo fim e aí
eu fiquei meio receoso porque eles vão
dizer naqueles caminhos se fim e aí eles
me olhar e falar assim a liberdade eu
acho que no final é sobre isso nosso
destino final Nosso principal objetivo é
a nossa principal ideia é a liberdade e
é isso que eu quero construir a poesia
falada são os nossos ancestrais soprando
os segredos para esse caminho só pra nas
rotas de fuga os caminhos para a
liberdade
e eu ainda quero fazer um poema para
criança eu ainda quero fazer uma
promessa especial para as que nasce com
a pele escura Eu ainda quero fazer um
versus Urano que toda a dor tem cura eu
tô na escrever um poema para as minhas
sobrinhas para maior que já é linda e
boa para quem quer ser dançarina de funk
e para que por enquanto só quer ser e um
outro porque tão pequeno nem chegou a
vingar Eu ainda tô na escrever um poema
que faça minha mãe chorar que deu
orgulho para o meus irmãos faça meu pai
me abraçar eu quero escrever um poema
que sirva de corda mas não para quando
eu quero sumir da terra e sim para
quando eu quero sair do fundo do poço só
brincar de cabo de guerra Eu ainda quero
escrever um poema que não tenha cheiro
de fundo do poço que não seja só sobre
como tudo tá osso Eu ainda quero fazer
um poema sem ter que falar de dor de
polícia de tiro um poema que seja menos
linha de sopa e mais venha de abraço
mais Ubuntu e menos gatilho
e eu ainda quero fazer um poema para
quem nem liga para chegar em primeiro eu
quero fazer um poema e dá para ver e que
não arreda o pé do meu peito terreiro eu
quero escrever um poema não é
recomendado para os maiores de dezoito
anos eu quero escrever um poema para
deixar a criança feliz tipo quando eu
colava Papai Noel na Quebrada no fim do
ano e nós ia correndo pegar brinquedo
com nariz cheio de Hum eu quero escrever
um poema sobre os sonhos sobre seu
Mestre Mandou pega Bandeira polícia e
ladrão eu quero rasgar todos os poemas
sobre os não que eu já levei e que foram
vários Eu quero um poema para nós ver
que nós é bem maior que o verme do
presidente Eu ainda quero aprender com
os poema em Libras Eu ainda quero fazer
um poema capoeira que seja a luta mas
que também seja dança e eu não vou ser o
primeiro poeta que diz Mas eu insisto
tem que ser tudo isso Pelas nossas
crianças
[Aplausos]